foreign
let's start from the beginning the
cosmos is around 13 billion years old
that's really old okay and in that
context we're a very young species
humans arrive around three four hundred
thousand years ago
um anatomically identical to all of us
and they're very successful they migrate
to a bunch of places they Master fire
but broadly speaking not much changes
until around 12 000 years ago the Advent
of Agriculture the Neolithic Revolution
now 12 000 years ago 10 000 BC they're
around 5 million of us walking the face
of the Earth but the population of
Ireland today
and what happens with agriculture is
that between 10 000 BC and 1800 A.D we
go from 5 million to 1 billion I mean
impressive you know real growth but then
something even more dramatic changes
probably not as big a rupture as
agriculture but it's called the
Industrial Revolution
and very quickly we go from 1 billion
and 1800 to 2 billion in 1923 billion
four billion and presently we had about
a billion people every 15 16 years now
this century and I think we're all
hopefully gonna be allowed to see it's
probably about the 2050s this Century
we're going to see something really
remarkable which is for the first time
in a really long time we're going to see
the planet's human population stagnate
and probably actually start to decline
so before 2100 we're looking at a
planetary population around 10 billion
people that's the that's the peak
that's a lot of people you know be very
demanding in terms of our planet's
resources but that's that's an important
thing to remember
and the reason why it's going to hit 10
billion and then either flatten or or
actually decline is because we're having
fewer children
okay that's a that's a global planetary
phenomenon which seems to map onto
literacy rates uh gender equality High
GDP high levels of secondary education
you know we see immediately falling
birth rates it's almost like a social
law
so we live um we're uh we're having
fewer children then secondly we're
living longer
and I think actually my grandmother is a
nice uh way of understanding this
Shuffle is a nice example my
grandmother's 96. she was born in 1926.
um she was one of eight
and they all survived now for the whole
of human history it's very common to
have large families what wasn't common
was for all the children to survive into
adulthood what changed after the early
1900s is infant mortality early years
mortality disappears which is why a
country like Iran where she's from can
go from 10 million people in 1900s to
around 80 million people today and uh
it'll probably be about 100 million in
in 20 years time
she and son has six children three boys
three girls
those six children have six
grandchildren and today those six
grandchildren have given her no great
grandchildren you can see where this is
going can't you
people are having fewer kids generation
on on generation
now I also have a niece her name is Zara
she's six
and while the possibility of my
grandmother living to a hundred when she
was born in 1926 it was more than a
hundred to one actually Zara who is six
I think she has statistically speaking
uh and evens chance of reaching 104. if
we see Trends since the 1840s Carry On
which they might not but hey they also
might accelerate then she has a 50 50
chance of living to 104 and I think this
is such a useful thoughts experiment for
everybody here you know my grandmother
born in 1926 saw the general strike you
know she was she was born when Adolf
Hitler was coming out of prison he
hadn't even ascended the the power yet
she was there for fascism the collapse
of the European uh colonial empires she
was there for the New Deal second world
war Space Race Cold War internet she's
still alive and I wonder what are the
things that Zara's gonna see by the
early 2100s what kind of a planet is she
going to see what kinds of technologies
will be around and I think we often
overstate the capacity for change in the
short term but underestimate it in the
long term and things are going to change
a heck of a lot in her life and one of
the trends underpinning that
and there are three big trends I think
actually that you'll see throughout her
life one of the trends like I said is
demographic aging the other two are
urbanization and climate change the
science fiction writer Bruce Sterling
has a wonderful formulation he says that
by 2050 we'll be a planet of older
people old people please don't get
sensitivized I'll be old we all get you
know older it's a wonderful thing about
all very equalizing uh phenomenon by
2050 will be a planet of older people in
big cities afraid of the sky which I
think is a wonderful formulation it's so
archaic and primitive uh but it would be
basically what's going on large cities
older people and catastrophic climate
change
so why is this a problem I mean these
are good things right living longer is a
good thing if my niece can live to 104
fantastic
um if we're having fewer children that's
great I mean it's manageable right you
see countries like China and China
become higher GDP countries they say
it's a good thing to have lower birth
rates so why am I saying this poses
challenges on a par with climate change
that's ridiculous
well it comes down to something called
the dependency ratio and this is new
material for me right this is my next
book so I will be referring to my notes
sometimes
today across the world there are 6.3
people of working age for every person
over 65.
6.3 the UN claims that figure will fall
to 3.4 to 1 by 2050 and 2.4 to 1 by
2100.
so it's 6.3 people of of working age for
every person over 65 today by 2100 it's
2.4
and what that means is we will have a
ever larger cluster of people in our
society it's called the oldest old
living to 1995 100 105 who have
extraordinary care needs
now at the beginning of the 20th century
the leading causes of death were often a
flu
cholera it was infection and then of
course we get a bunch of new
technologies and that becomes less an
issue today the leading cause of death
globally are age-related
cardiac disease cancer stroke and
actually do you know what the biggest
cause of death in the UK is now
philosophical five six years
is dementia which is remarkable I mean
that's actually the that signifies a
hugely successful Society if people
people are dying because they're just
you know that's kind of as far as we can
go as a species so far then that's a
real sign of of progress
but it also means really big problems
because cancer treatment treatment for
heart disease stroke can be quite
resource resource-utensive but as
anybody here who has an older relative
knows or a friend who's suffering from
Dementia or cognitive decline that is
extraordinarily expensive to deal with
very expensive and so the idea that
we're somehow going to have what we
presently have this weird amalgam of the
market and the state to look after
millions of people in our societies with
cognitive impairments and dementia
clearly ridiculous
so the first thing I would propose to
take away and I know when we have these
talks that I mean I'd come to talk so I
barely remember anything I sometimes
remember one thing the one thing I would
want to impress on people is the need
for a national care service for people
in older age it's going to become a
necessity I think even center-right
politicians will be demanding it soon
and people say well we can't afford a
national Care Service it's too expensive
you go to the complete Wrong Way Around
we can't afford not to have a national
Care Service a great example is the US
the U.S spends today
I love doing this because I go to I did
a TED Talk in Vancouver recently it's
really great to put this in the face of
North Americans
although Canadians have a Public Health
Care system in their defense
in the U.S they spend around these
change all the time with covert and
whatnot but the U.S spends around 17 of
its economy it's GDP on Healthcare 17
the UK spends around nine percent now I
know it's not perfect in the UK we could
probably bump it up by one or two
percent and we'd have the sort of
service we had 10 11 years ago which I
thought was personally I thought was
very good service
so they spend more of their economy on
health care and yet
lower life expectancy more women die in
childbirth higher rates of infant
mortality and tens of millions of people
aren't covered
so I mean I think the UK system of what
you'd call single-payer maybe in the US
is the closest analog that makes sense
if you've got this challenge of of
elderly care
so let's look at some of the numbers in
2013 standard and poor found as a result
of demographic aging 60 of the countries
they analyzed would see their credit
status reduced to junk within a
generation
three years later they published a less
pessimistic report which was only a
quarter of countries but hold on these
are pretty big countries they noticed
that Ukraine Brazil China Saudi Arabia
all face major problems purely as a
result of demographic Aging in the UK
the cost of Health and Social care the
state pension and other benefits
forecast to increase annual spending by
2.5 percent of GDP every year in the
decade after 2020. the specific data for
the UK between 2016 and 2030 Britain's
over 65s will grow by a third while the
oldest old those people who need really
extensive resources and and care and
attention those over 85 will almost
double so when politicians talk about
balancing the books small state my God
you really you really have I think lost
the plot you look at climate change you
clearly need a bigger State and I think
you look at something like demographic
aging again you need a big estate
we're going to have a real problem on
our hands if people think that serco and
Sodexo and capita and G4S are going to
sort this out they can't even do Olympic
Security
that's true or recruitment for the
British army okay and so when carillion
collapses okay well it's a construction
company or okay some businesses get hit
and some trades people they went
bankrupt it's terrible but we can't have
we can't have companies like this
failing and collapsing when we've got
people in elderly care who aren't even
cognitively capable of helping
themselves this is a serious serious
point and I hope it gains a consensus
across the political divide
but it's not just the economics of this
of an aging Society of a society of
older people and big cities afraid of
the sky this goes beyond just public
policy and Welfare and and
taxpayer and how we're going to have to
order our our state and our market and
their relationship to one another it
goes beyond that because demographic
aging is also going to inflect our
political cultures
um we are going to become gerontocracies
again this is not meant to be critical
whenever I talk about this thank you so
you're being you know you're being
ageist I'm going to be able to you know
when I'm talking about 2050 I'll be one
of the older people uh and I think this
is an important conversation for us to
have as a as a species it's one of the
things we share we all grow old uh so I
would really be upset if you thought I
was being ages when I say we're going to
become gerontocracies because in a way
it's already it's already starting to
happen
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas